what were you the god of again
[Music]
even when you had to I you'll see only
half the picture it's too strong
about my hammer icon are you saw the god
of hammers hmm hey everybody its charlie
happy april infinity war is coming in
less than a month so this is going to be
my updated Power Rankings I just did the
top 10 because they're a crazy number of
characters during infinity war but you
have like a couple different tiers of
power levels you have a couple people
that are almost as powerful it's cosmic
level beings then you have a bunch of
like normal human characters they just
have a lot of tech or a lot of upgrades
that make them really powerful so if you
are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's crazy stuff happening
between now infinity war and Deadpool 2
and there's an Infinity Gauntlet replica
giveaway going on all you have to do
tension that just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video try to take
into account how some of these
characters have been changed from their
comic book versions and I also took into
account things that Kevin Feige said
about the characters or whether or not
they would normally be wielding things
like Infinity stones so just trying to
take into account the current state of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe starting
with number 10 and number 9 also you
know kind of relatively equal but I put
black panther at number 10 because he
normally doesn't fight with all of the
door mulashi but like if he actually got
to use all of his resources and he were
in Wakanda during the fight that he
would normally be much more powerful
because he commands that great army he
has all that technology but for the most
part when Black Panther is fighting
people he's normally just wearing his
one suit by himself so even though he's
a total badass and way more powerful
than most of the Avengers he's not quite
as powerful as the Avengers that wield
Infinity stones like I said though
number nine almost as equal just a
little more powerful is Iron Man because
unlike Black Panther he rolls around
with his support system so he has all
those crazy armors he has for Annika
waiting in orbit ready at a moment's
notice it's not like Black Panther keeps
a satellite with a bunch of dorm Ellijay
in orbit so that wherever he is on
planet earth he could just call it in a
moment's notice there are a couple of
technologies that both of them have they
can swap
that ranking but only if you give them a
bunch of extra things that they don't
normally fight with so that's why I put
Black Panther an Iron Man right there
right above them number eight the Hulk
because he should have near limitless
strength but per that vision an age of
Ultron we know that he can be
overpowered and we're not really talking
about world breaker Hulk we're not
talking about Herald of Galactus Hulk
wielding the power cosmic this is just
like the normal version of the Hulk he
got crazy powerful during Ragnarok but
Thor was able to overpower him number
seven Scarlet Witch because she wields
some of the powers of an infinity stone
but she doesn't totally understand them
she's still in the process of leveling
up so she's unpredictable
you could overpower her it depends on
how crazy she gets in how long you've
given her to study her powers and it
doesn't seem like she spends a whole lot
of time studying her abilities number
six is Thor wielding his own inner
godlike power in the comics he wields
the Thor force but that's only after he
absorbs the odinforce so we really can't
call it that in the movies you can call
it whatever you want his inner lightning
it gives him the ability to fly he is
effectively a living God and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but not quite as
powerful as Odin was and as you can see
from the infinity war trailer not nearly
as powerful as Thanos who's not using
any of the power of the Infinity stones
when he's in this scene here like he's
literally just grabbing him with one of
his hands that's how strong he is
next up number five vision because he
wields the mine stone and he actually
does kind of know how to use it like
he's a machine so he has limitless
endurance he will not get tired unlike
all of the other Avengers that are like
purely biological normal creatures like
they get tired they have to eat they
have to sleep vision doesn't have to do
any of those things so if you assume
that the Hulk could get mad enough to
soak a blast from the mind gem you just
have to remember that vision doesn't get
tired eventually the Hulk will tire out
it'll just take forever to get there the
reason why it seems like he's so weak
during the infinity war trailer is is
because so many of the Black Order are
teaming up against him so that
technically doesn't count like this is a
one-on-one situation type of thing
people by themselves like if the entire
Black Order teamed up it would seem like
vision is really weak when actually he's
super powerful
but also just like Scarlet Witch he
doesn't fully understand his powers but
remember he's made of vibranium the
strongest metal on earth so like you
would have to be a cosmic level being in
order to defeat him unless it was a
really big tag-team situation which it
is during infinity war number four is
Captain Marvel really only because Kevin
Feige said she's gonna be the most
powerful character that they've ever
introduced but without knowing exactly
how they're gonna give her her powers in
the comics she doesn't wield an infinity
stone she has what you would call cosmic
level power she absorbs energy too so if
vision actually tried to blast her with
the mind gem like he could blast Hulk
she could absorb that use it to power
herself up go binary and then shoot it
right back at him so like what she
really wants to power up in a big fight
and she's running low on energy
she'll have one of the other Avengers or
the other Ultimates who give off energy
based powers just shoot her in the chest
so she can absorb their energy and power
back up like I need a recharge somebody
blast me in the face the other thing
about Captain Marvel 2 is that during
the course of infinity war in Avengers 4
she's being Captain Marvel for a long
time so she's had a while to figure her
powers out unlike vision and Scarlet
Witch that have only had their powers
for a little while given enough time
anybody that wields an infinity stone
could become more powerful which I'll
explain when I talk about the cosmic
beings but number 3 Doctor Strange
because he wields the time stone so he's
a very learned person he's the sorcerer
supreme so he's the most powerful magic
user on planet earth but also he
normally wields the time stone so you
would expect him to use that in a fight
which takes his power levels off the
charts and he was able to sort of
outsmart Dormammu who is effectively the
next most powerful being assuming that
you don't have Galactus inside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Dormammu was
like the dark threat that they could
turn into the phase 4 phase 5 villain if
they don't get Galactus but you have to
remember to the Doctor Strange being a
physician being someone who is
obsessively learned like he just spends
all of his time reading about arcane
knowledge learning new abilities he
would be just as smart as people like
Sheree or Iron Man relative to his own
speciality and he normally has access to
all these arcane objects so
without the infinity stone he still has
a lot of special power-ups that he could
bring to bear during a fight that you
would normally expect him to use so top
two these should be kind of obvious at
this point number two is actually Thanos
even without the Infinity Gauntlet or
any of the Infinity stones he's able to
soak a blast from the odinforce Odin is
one of the most powerful beings in the
universe so that's how powerful normal
level Thanos is once he gets all the
Infinity stones in the Infinity Gauntlet
there are really only one or two
characters that could possibly take him
down and those characters aren't inside
the movies so you can't really count
them for the purpose of this list my
number one is kind of funny but people
don't think about it that often they
reek and eyes it during guardians of the
galaxy too so you can add them to the
list because they exist but it's the
Watchers because they're not nipa ttan
but forbidden to interfere
so without introducing some more cosmic
beings they technically are the most
powerful people even though they're just
gonna have to sit there and watch what
they a nose does and watch this play out
and here's the really cool thing on top
of this list so Marvel actually like in
the last five or so years killed off
three people who were vastly more
powerful than most of the people on this
list you have the ancient one who was
alive for thousands of years had that
whole time to learn how to fully use the
time stone and she also wielded the
powers of the Dark Dimension to protect
the earth from people like Thanos which
is probably the reason why Thanos didn't
come to earth sooner because the ancient
one was still alive and Odin was still
alive too he protected the nine realms
Midgard earth is one of the nine realms
this is a pretty easy way to explain why
this is just happening now because the
time stone the eye of agamotto has been
around for a long time the aether was
hidden within the earth for eons the
other ones they just killed off is ego
the Living Planet one of the most
powerful beings in the universe the
Celestials regardless of who they are
what their specific power set are are
meant to be that top tier level of power
but let me know in the comments who are
your top three favorite most powerful
characters and what'll happen is is I'm
working on my ready player one Easter
Egg video I'll post that next hopefully
before the end of tonight got to do some
family stuff because it's Easter it's
the holidays but I'll say
congratulations
Daniel Vega you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please
private message me so I can get your
contact details so be a new round when I
post new Marvel click here for that team
Thor infinity war trailer and click here
for the test trailer from that animated
Deadpool series thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]